hi guys how are you doing
good how are you hi i'm doing very well
thank you for
talking to me i absolutely love this
series
i am from los angeles so disneyland is
my theme park i've been going since i
was a
very young child frequented over the
years continue to go to this day and
now cover theme parks so it's very cool
to have something like this
and i'm curious what was your first
disney theme park experience
and what made you see what the parks
could offer
wow all right i guess i'll start since i
said wow all right i have to admit
something i did not get to my first
disney park until i was an adult
and moved to los angeles so i was in my
20s
um early 20s when i moved here and
that was my first experience and when i
had been to theme parks on the east
coast
my family uh we didn't go down to walt
disney world as much as i would have
wanted to um so i think my first
experience truly was walking to
disneyland and it was
again unlike any other theme park i
haven't ever been to before it
immediately captured me emotionally just
sort of
being there seeing that train going
underneath that train going and seeing
main street and just that experience
um i'll never forget it so that was my
first experience
i'm a california native um from northern
california so disneyland was my first
disney park experience i was probably i
was about six years old
when i first went um i don't have too
many
memories about it i do know my parents
like to tell me that from that moment on
i was
pretty much obsessed and they had to
take me to disneyland
once a year every every year from that
moment on
and it just became a tradition for my
family we would drive down to
anaheim and go to disneyland for a few
days um and eventually
disney world was added to that itinerary
we started to go there when i was in my
teens
um and then as a 20 i finally got to go
to tokyo disneyland in tokyo disneysea
so i just i love visiting our parks
around the world it's it's just fun and
exciting and there's just so much to see
and do
and it's an incredible experience
did you guys always have a goal of
someday working
for disney i mean at what point
did you decide that was something you
wanted to do and what kind of a path did
it take to get there
you know i moved to los angeles and
again i hadn't been to a disney park
until i moved to los
angeles but um you know i came out to be
in the entertainment business i wanted
to be a writer and a filmmaker
um and and that's the that's the career
i started i started working in
television and both production and as a
writer
um but disney of course is one of
one of the biggest of the entertainment
companies with some of the greatest
stories ever
told in the entertainment business so i
wanted to absolutely work with disney
right from the get-go really first in
television um and film
but then as soon as i started my first
imaginary project i never wanted to
leave
so um it's been now
20 years of that yeah i've definitely
i've always wanted to work for disney
um i started with with my local disney
store
about 20 years ago now that was that was
my foot in the door to the walt disney
company
um and i've been been part of it ever
since i
came to imaginarian as an intern about
15 years ago working with this amazing
art collection
um and i'm still there so it's
definitely it's always been a passion of
mine
and i'm honored to get to be part of
that and part of the team that
continues to care for the collection and
the artwork
it seems like a project like this would
be kind of cool for you guys too because
being an imagineer and working in
imaginary has so many different i mean
there's so many different types of jobs
and departments and things that
everybody can do
that it seems like it might be hard to
explain that to friends and family and
now you can just point them to a show
like this
[Music]
absolutely absolutely agreed well
i'm curious i mean the average theme
park goer enjoying the parks
likely takes the blood sweat and tears
from all the work for granted because
they're just
experiencing the finished product but
every little detail on any disney
property is important
so however big or small is there
something that that just most excites
you
every time you've seen it or learning
about it just some like little detail
that
you think is really cool i kind of
experience our parks differently now i i
like to just go and
wander if that makes sense i'm not
necessarily there to ride a particular
attraction or anything i just
i like to be in the place and experience
it
and and people watch and you know spend
time with friends and for family
it's just it's it's a nice environment
to just hang out in that's really
something that i enjoy
with the parks i do that a lot so i
completely get that
yeah i mean and i ain't completely i
think um
i there's never um i never stopped being
curious about the parks because there's
so much there
um and there's these nooks and crannies
that i haven't really spent time in
right and it's just like wow i haven't
really hung out in this part of the park
before
and be that any of the parks and some of
those parts some of the parks like
like disney and disney's animal kingdom
really encourage
lots of wandering down trails and things
that you don't you know where it's going
to go
so it's i think what's wonderful is that
we have different kinds of parks too not
just the castle park
um but even just walking down main
street it's just like oh i hadn't really
seen that before it's so cool
and there's always no surprises when you
know about the secrets can you still
experience the magic because it seems
like
you know there might be that bit of you
know does it take anything away once you
know
how it all works i do think you have to
put that out of your mind and just try
to get yourself back into sort of be in
that guest
sort of mind frame um um
luckily for me as a writer and someone
who's focused on the story the whole
time so maybe on a project for five
years
but i'm sort of living in the story the
whole time so to me
i know there's this technology here and
that crazy wall is over there and all
that but
um i'm always thinking about it just
truly immersed in the storytelling so
for me i'm always going to live in it as
a real place
yeah same you know once once you're on
an attraction
you just forget about that you're
instantly immersed in whatever that
that story is or space you're
experiencing
um you know for me i'll sometimes maybe
think of a piece of art that inspired
the space that i'm in
so that that's kind of it doesn't
detract from it i think for me it adds
to it to go
oh that started looking like that and
then that's what was built so
that kind of adds another fun layer for
me
yeah i mean vanessa when you started
working in the position that you're in
did you have any expectations of what
you might learn from the work that you
would get to do as far as
you know working with all these
collections of content
i mean was the the volume of it more
than you ever expected
um you know coming into the interview
for my current role
i didn't even know what i was
interviewing for i was told it was a
library so i was expecting books
um which is part of what what is in the
building i'm in but
on the way over there like it's the art
library it's where all the artwork for
imagineering is stored we're now known
as the art collection
so i i figured it would be a lot but i
didn't know it was
as much as it actually is um
it's it's kind of overwhelming at times
there's there's
so much history there so much artwork
has been created over the years
um it's it's pretty it's an amazing
archive
for sure is there an attraction
or land that has never materialized that
you still wish
could someday end up in one of the theme
parks
well that's a hard one because i think
that you know the creative process is
such that
these things are never really not
happening they're always just in a state
of creative process right i mean that
we're thinking about things all the time
and pieces of
one thing may end up in another thing
and so there isn't really sort of that
thing that never happened it's really
just this idea that there's um
those things we're working on and
thinking about and
[Music]
working towards yeah
i agree and a lot of times an idea
you know maybe evolves so it's it's not
exactly what was planned but you can see
that
it inspired what was ultimately built
in the parks is there a
some sort of attraction that used to be
at one of the parks that you wish
you could bring back if there were no
restrictions to being able to do so
i really i can't think of one that would
i would say it should come back because
i think the things that may have gone
there now are equally exciting if
if not more so so i think that it's just
you know i think
it's always an evolution of of things
that offerings
um and that's what's so exciting about
the work we do at imagineering it's
always
evolving into these new things yeah i
don't know that there's neces
necessarily something i'd want to see
come back um
but it would be fun to time travel back
and maybe experience some things
magic skyway is one of those attractions
i always wish i could have
seen in person gone to the world's fair
in new york and
experienced that but you know i can
still see the dinosaurs from that so
i'll take that
yeah yeah i think my my heart will
always wish that i could see the country
bears again in anaheim because
it's a little harder when you live in la
to get to florida to see them
yeah tokyo yeah well i love how
there's sort of this running theme of
you know at the time this ride
was imagined the technology wasn't there
yet but
you know that's okay we'll just work on
it till it is it seemed to always come
together
does it feel like especially you know
when you're working in imagineering that
you're encouraged to imagine things for
theme parks that seem impossible
because for the most part everyone has
learned that technology will catch up
eventually
yeah i mean i think it's a big part of
it i think the show captures this really
wonderfully and it shows i think again i
go back to the
star wars episode thinking star tours
and just think of like
they had ideas they had technology how
do these two things come together
when what's the right sequence of these
things what would ultimately become and
i just think
the show does a wonderful job of
capturing that kind of discovery
that happens during during a project
not even before the project's begun but
you're already into it you're trying to
still discover things and figure out
um how it's going to go it's not always
a straight line here
line from a piece of concept art and
idea to
attraction there is a lot of twists and
turns on that road
but do get there and i think that's what
makes the work of imaginary so exciting
is not necessarily knowing fully at the
beginning how you are going to get there
but you are
yeah and i love how in disneyland we
sort of get that representation of both
sides of it of you know star tours is
still there which was
so cutting edge at the time as far as
putting guests in that world of star
wars
but then you also have rise of the
resistance there which is
really literally like putting guests in
the action of star wars
and i think it's really cool that you
can sort of get to see both of those
still
side by side in one park absolutely
yeah i agree with that that was a fun
episode for me to watch as someone you
know i'm not involved in that creative
process so to get to see that
on screen and hear those stories being
told i was excited about that
is there a ride in one of the parks that
you feel like you always have to go on
even if you only get to one ride when
you go
yes
uh for me it's it's a grand circle tour
on the disneyland railroad that's my
go-to um when i go with my friends
you have to take me on the train like
that's what we're gonna do
hard to argue with that i'm with the
mess on that one
i will try to go to one of the classics
upon the mansion or pirates as well
but sometimes the lines are too long
yeah yeah for me it's it's always
definitely haunted mansion i've always
loved that ride and it's so funny to
hear the
arguing back and forth in this between
is it funny is it scary and it's always
kind of been both of those things or
sometimes
it's one and not the other depending on
what mood you might be in that day
exactly and i just i kind of love that
for me like as long as i go on that ride
i feel like that encompasses so much of
disney i feel like i can just spend the
rest of the day walking around and not
riding anything else and it feels like a
complete day
yeah yeah totally true as well
is there a ride you guys haven't gotten
to experience in one of the
other like you know far away parks that
you still
hope to yes
i've only been to um anaheim florida
and tokyo so i really want to go to
shanghai and ride pirates the caribbean
over there i've
all i hear are great things about it and
i've seen some photos and video and i
want to experience that in person
yeah same i want to get to shanghai
shanghai pirates i have not done that
yet
well i'm i'm a third vote for that so
well thank you guys for talking to me i
appreciate it thank you
take care